hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the important role of lncrnas
and breast cancer I am Robert
Castellanos of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by a few matrix a free matrix
technologies enable multiplex and
simultaneous analysis of biological
systems at the cell protein and gene
level facilitating the rap translation
of bench top research into clinical and
routine use for human health and
wellness athle matrix part of thermo
fisher scientific provides leadership
and support with customers and
pharmaceutical diagnostics and
biotechnology companies and leading
academic government and nonprofit
research institutes in their quest to
use biology for a better world to learn
more please visit affymetrix com we have
a few an important announcements before
we begin this webcast is designed to be
interactive and may encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as you
can any questions we are not able to
answer today will be answered offline
via email you can enlarge the slide
window by clicking on the screen icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
window have any technical problems
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your problem to the
green Q&A button lower left I would like
to introduce today's speakers dr.
Rebecca Duvall and dr. alfredo Hidalgo
Merrin dr. de veau earned her BS in
biochemistry at Virginia Tech in 2008
followed by her PhD in pharmacology from
the university of north carolina in 2013
her graduate training under dr.
Angelique Whitehurst
strong understanding mechanisms of
resistance to anti mitosis targeted
chemotherapeutics and lung cancer for
this work she integrated both medium and
high throughput screening platforms to
discover new therapeutic entry points
and 2014 dr. Davila joined the lab at
the center Cancer Research Center at the
University of Albany where she
investigating the wool of long
non-coding RNAs and promoting breast
cancer progression her work is supported
by the US Department of Defense breast
cancer research program break the reward
I would now like to turn it over to dr.
DeVoe for her presentation good morning
and thank you and I would like to thank
both Abby metrics and lab roots for the
opportunity to share this ongoing
project with everyone today one project
in the Hirsch woods lab here at the
University at Albany Cancer Research
Center he has focused on the study of
long non-coding RNAs as functional
drivers of invasive breast cancer to
begin I first just want to orient
everybody as to the cellular progression
leading to invasive breast cancer the
vast majority of breast cancers will
develop in the duct of the normal
mammary gland in the normal duct ordered
epithelial cells will align into a
hollow lumen and sit on a basement
membrane now continuous loss of normal
epithelial cell function underlies
breast cancer progression to first a
state of atypical ductal hyperplasia
which is characterized by abnormal
growth this may further progress to
ductal carcinoma in sight you these
cells contain all the features of
malignancy however they remain contained
within the duct this is considered a non
obligated precursor and it's not until
these cells gain the ability to invade
beyond the duct that we have an invasive
ductal carcinoma an invasive disease
potential
metastatic and life-threatening now as
increased advances in our imaging
technology and increased emphasis on
early detection there's been a dramatic
increase in the diagnosis of ductal
carcinoma over the past 30 years while
early detection remains incredibly
important we have since learned that
only around forty percent of the it's
DCIS cases ever progressed becoming an
invasive disease currently we do not
understand the biology underlying the
progression from ductal carcinoma in
sight you to an invasive lesion
therefore currently all GIS patients are
treated by either search by surgery with
or without radiation therapy as well as
the option of hormone intervention this
has created a tremendous state of
overdiagnosis and overtreatment and just
to highlight how pendant this is this is
an article recently published in the Los
Angeles Times addressing this issue and
summarizing this new publication in the
New England Journal of Medicine looking
at the current state of overdiagnosis
now while there are a few predictive
tests available to DC I ask patients
there is really a critical need to
better understand the underlying biology
to both better give diagnostics and
prognosis for our DC as patients and to
discover new therapeutic entry points
now in the Hirsch codes lab we
hypothesize that long non-coding RNAs or
link rnase maybe these key functional
determinants of progression now long
non-coding RNAs rrnas of at least 200
nucleotides long with no coding
potential for a long time they are
disregarded as genomic junk however now
we are realizing that they contribute to
almost every aspect of gene regulation
they can both inhibit or encourage
transcriptional
initiation they can alter the
transcripts splicing a transcript
stability or translation beyond
interacting or altering a transcript
they can also interact with protein
complexes here highlighted link rnase
can recruit chromatin modifying
complexes altering epigenetic patterns
resulting in broad changes to
transcriptional programs now today over
10,000 link rnase have been reported
however very few have defined mechanisms
of action now given their plethora of
potential functions we believe that this
is a class of RNAs that is it's a class
of irony as that is largely untapped as
drivers of disease progression as well
as potential therapeutic entry points
now for my project in order to define
those link rnase that are important to
DC is progression in collaboration with
dr. Freda they pod at the University of
Kansas Medical Center patients that
exhibit both a DC is legion adjacent to
an invasive lesion were identified this
system allows for the direct comparison
of pre invasive versus invasive disease
now biopsies of both the dcs lesion
indicated in B and the invasive lesion
indicated in C were collected from five
patients and RNA sequencing was
performed this analysis revealed a
cohort of 33 link rnase whose expression
can distinguish between DCIS and
invasive breast cancer while the power
of this model is that the link rnase
were discovered directly from patient
samples in order to study these link
rnase
in the lab returned to the mcf10a breast
cancer progression model this model um
is composed of four cell lines that were
all originally derived from the mcf10a
cells but now we capitulate several
different stages of progression here I
want to focus on the DCIS which we
capitulate abductor personal insight ooh
mm cf10 I ca1 cells which are are
invasive line now screaming through our
cohort of link RNAs we do find several
candidate link rnase with intriguing
expression patterns through this series
however our most interesting link RNA is
a link seven here we can see in my delek
stepwise expression pattern where the
link RNA is enriched with disease
progression now while this is a cell
culture-based model we are always
looking to increase our patient sample
number either with fresh samples or
archived so if there's anybody out there
who is working on DCIS and finds this
interesting we love to chat so you know
common question with link rnase is are
they functional where are they just bits
of trans transcription that occur
randomly is this link RNA actually
functioning to promote progression or is
it a byproduct of disease progression
now in order to begin to address this
question we turn to SI rna-mediated
loss-of-function studies here we see we
are able to get depletion of our link
RNA and through P I staining and flow
cytometry we notice that with depletion
of our link RNA we see loss of our g2m
mitotic compartment with a correspond
relative to our control with a
corresponding increase in our g0 g1
compartment together suggesting that our
link RNA is supporting cell cycle
progression complementing this we also
in our C attenuation of long term
proliferative attempt
in our colony formation assay further
suggesting that this link RNA is somehow
functioning to support to Marcel
progression or tumor cell cycle I'm
third complementing our essay
rna-mediated studies we also are using
ASO mediated depletion asos our anti
sense oligonucleotides that activate RN
ACH to leave both nuclear and
cytoplasmic transcripts this achieves
better knock down and our phenotypic
result is that we find increase a pop
taught excels is indicated by this
fourth compartment with increase in x
and 5 now interestingly we find that
depletion of link 7 preferentially kills
our DZ is and RCA one sells relative to
our normal mcf10a cells this suggests
that targeting this link RNA may provide
a therapeutic window for future
investigation now so so far I've told
you that link 7 has been identified
directly from patient cells as enriched
in the invasive lesions the preliminary
evidence suggests that this link RNA
support spoke tumor cell viability and
cell cycle proliferation and cell cycle
progression so what exactly is link
seven now ceiling in on its genomic
Bogut's explained that link 7 is a
naturally occurring anti-sense
transcript this is a link RNA that is
transcribed off the opposite strand and
it is found in a head-to-head fashion
with an associated protein coding gene
what is really interesting to me about
this is that this genomic architecture
is actually very common we find link
rnase miss anti-sense orientation in
more than ten percent of our known
protein coding genes so as we discover
how link rnase function this could be a
very abundant new level regulation
to consider now these head-to-head
transcripts can be driven by the same
promoter or they can be driven by
discreet promoters and now as link rnase
are largely unstudied it is always very
important to go into your system and
determine what exactly is expressed in
your cells and is the predicted sequence
information actually correct now in
order to do this um we use an experiment
called rapid amplification of cdna ends
or race using available commercially
available kits now what ways essentially
does is it provides a tag on either the
extreme 5 prime end or 3 prime end of
your transcripts this then allows you to
pcr amplified from any known portion of
your transcript throw to the extreme end
thus defining the transcription start
site or the transcription stop site now
for this analysis we use our DCI at
zones and our invasive ca1 cells and
gratifyingly although this is not
quantitative we do see a shift in both
isoform expression and abundance in
between our DCIS and RCA one sells our
sequencing analysis demonstrates that
the transcript expressed in our cells
actually has an extended five prime end
this demonstrates that our link RNA has
an even larger overlapping region with
our protein coding gene than initially
predicted we are further able to harvest
publicly available grossie data which
indicates that and this gross seek data
is separated to the negative strand and
the positive strand looking at the
negative strand we do see Peaks
indicating that our link RNA does become
expressed so now we validated how our
link RNA is transcript as well as the
fact that
it does become express themselves okay
so it is a very common feature that link
I anaise given this associated protein
coding gene overlapping architecture can
regulate the associated protein coding
gene and in fact this is true in our
case we find that equation of our link
RNA also results in depletion of our
associated protein coding gene on
transcript and this level of depletion
is sufficient to prevent or to attenuate
expression of that indicated protein now
these results could be obtained through
a multiple through multiple mechanisms
one hypothesis was that the link RNA was
regulating the protein coding genes
transcript stability due to that
overlapping architecture however
following treatment with actin alliance
and neat we find that the link RNA does
not alter the protein coding gene
transcript stability on taken together
we now believe that this link RNA may
directly regulate the transcription of
the associated protein coding gene I
just want to step back and go look at
that focus what we see when looking at
publicly available data is that this
locus is heavily marked by h3k4me3 h3
and h3k27me3 that this is an active
enhancer region therefore this link RNA
alone is part of a class of newly
described rnase that are transcribed
from enhancers this is a new enhancer
associated RNA furthermore we see on
occupancy of ctcf of ctcf as
demonstrated in this diagram
here is important for anchoring the
cohesion complex a cohesion complex is a
multi-protein complex that functions to
tie together pieces of chromatin linking
an enhancer region with a promoter
region thereby allowing one enhancer to
regulate multiple regions of the
transcript this together suggests that
this region may be participating in
chromatin looping now to determine if
that is the case vising again probably
available data we looked at chromatin
loops in our mcf10a s versus our vs
cancer cells now in this circus flan
each line indicates a chromosomal
interaction initiating from our region
of interest this suggests that in
between our normal and tumor cells we
find an increase in our chromosome
looping around this region as link rnase
have previously been identified to
interact with chromosome looping
machinery future studies will be focused
on determining if our link RNA is
directly altering chromatin moving
around this enhancer promoting to
promote breast cancer progression now
finally to determine the consequences of
our link RNA expression recurring to
affymetrix human transcriptome array to
point o in order to define those genes
that become either depleted or enriched
following link RNA knock down this array
has been very helpful in and will be
used further to define exactly the
consequences of our link RNA expression
final going back to our dcs regression
model future studies will be focused on
an orthotopic model of DCIS
Shin whereby dca cells are injected
directly into the mammary duct and
allowed to progress and grow for six to
eight weeks during this time you can see
on the right DCIS lesions form
preliminary studies in this model have
indicated that in vivo expression of our
link RNA becomes enriched the longer the
cells are able to progress in vivo so in
conclusion today when I hope I've
highlighted for you is that long
non-coding RNAs can be very important
molecules when considering breast cancer
progression we've identified a cohort of
link RNAs that can distinguish DC is
from invasive breast cancer and we've
identified a link RNA that can promote
your cell cycle and viability we believe
in future studies will define the
mechanism by which this link RNA can
function insists to regulate its
associated protein coding gene and also
we will determine how this link RNA may
affect blood transcriptional programs
through altering chromatin looping we
are very excited to be investigating
these important new class of genetic
regulators that I would like you to
think on the entire her jewett
especially my adviser days and her shoe
it's our collaborators who are
absolutely essential to this progress
success rebe of a bod and christian
chlorophyll our Center for functional
genomics at SUNY Albany and our entire
research center very much
well thank you for that informative
presentation I like to introduce now mmm
dr. hill hidalgo Miranda dr. alfredo
Hidalgo Miranda was born in mexico city
in 1973 he said a biology and graduated
with honors from the National University
of Mexico UN am in 1997 in 2005 he
received his PhD in biological sciences
from the Faculty of Medicine for un am
between 1997 and 1999 he was a visiting
scientist at the molecular oncology
laboratory of the von virtual Institute
of Pathology the devon humboldt
university in berlin germany in 2004 he
joined the National Institute of genomic
medicine in Mexico City where he has
participated in several products
including the analysis of genomic
diversity of the Mexican population and
setting up genomic analysis core
laboratories since 2013 dr. Hidalgo
Miranda has led cancer genomics
laboratory of the National Institute of
genomic medicine where his main research
focus is a systematic analysis of
somatic alterations leading to human
cancer his group uses high-throughput
genomic analysis tools in order to
identify changes in the genome and
transcriptome a breast tumors including
DNA copy number aberrations changes in
mrna micro RNA and lncrnas pressions and
how they may be related to tumor biology
the cancer genome group has also
involved and the analysis of whole
genome and exome sequencing a breast
uterine cervix lymphoma and head and
neck tumors leading to the
identification of several genomic
immoralities whose role and human cancer
was not previously recognized I'll now
turn it over to dr. Hidalgo Miranda for
his presentation
well thank you very much for the
presentation and thank you very much
Rebecca for it for that very nice
presentation I will let you know I would
like to begin thanking elaborates and
affymetrix for the opportunity of
presenting the results of living
gathering for the last year's regarding
our analysis in different sources of
information of genetic information in
breast cancer so as you know breast
cancer is a very heterogeneous disease
this heterogeneity is for is reflected
both in the clinical sense where we can
find several responses to current
treatments but also at the molecular
level and the most relevant differences
between breast tumors which are
clinically important is mainly derived
from the expression of several markers
which are used in the clinical setting
in order to define therapy basically the
hormone receptors and the expression of
hair too and this will be very useful in
order to select targets a therapist for
this type of patients but there are also
another group of tumors which are very
important because they have a very bad
clinical outcome and a very very bad
biological behavior which are the triple
negative tumors which are of course
since they don't express either a
hormone receptors or here too they
cannot be treated with get with targeted
therapies and since they are very
aggressive they represent a very
important clinical problem for breast
cancer and this was one of the first
ways that we found that there is tighter
than 18 in breast tumors but also when
we began working with that different
expression and methods basically
microarrays the different different
groups described that using several
patterns of gene expression you can find
at least five different subgroups of
breast cancer which I also related with
a with a clinical failure of these
tumors so this led to the development of
the specific tools where you can use the
expression in order to define a specific
risk for a specific patients in order to
make clinical decisions so this has
become
very important tool in order to not only
characterize a classic by breast cancer
but also as a clinical decision-making
tool for clinicians in this sense we can
also find heterogeneity within the
breast cancer subtypes in this is like
you can see that there are also several
groups that have been working on
defining ket originated within the
triple negative breast tumors and there
are at least five or six different
subgroups within the triple negative
subtype and some of them are also
related with a back technical behavior
or with a bad response to current
treatment but we should remind that
these most of the information that we
have already described is based on the
expression of messenger RNAs but the
human transcriptome is far more complex
than just the coning needs if we can if
you take a look at the latest data we
can find that the coding rnase are only
thirty-five percent of the genes encoded
in the in the human genome and not more
than forty percent of these genes i I'm
from Long from non-coding genes and you
can separate this one's bold in the
small non-coding RNA genes mainly the
microRNAs and the low non-coding RNA
genes which are more than 50,000 already
described in the literature so it's very
important as Rebecca as stated in a
presentation to turn our attention in
the potential run of non-coding RNAs
both of the biological sense and as a
potential tool to classify and to
understand a tumor heterogeneity in
breast cancer so these type this links
are in this Lincoln relays can can have
different types of the Pentagon their
origin they can be intronic transcripts
they can be promoted they can be
associated with a promoter associated
transcript and depending on their own
they're on their on their location on
the enum you can classify the number of
lung and colon rnase and also this is a
slide that already there traffic already
represented they can have a different
and several biological roles in the cell
so it's really difficult to understand
what's going
when you find a differential expression
of particular arena and you really have
to be very careful and what kind of
experiment you should try to decide know
that to demonstrate what's the specific
biological role of a particular link
harmony so with all these things in mind
we were simple years ago we've been
analyzing a expression patterns of
breast cancer in Mexican patients and
this is because in Mexico breast cancer
is one of the most important illogical
problems and feo population breast
cancer is the first concept
cancer-related that in the Mexican
population there's a major prevalence in
young women more than 500 5000 a woman
died due to breast cancer every year and
also there is a very if you check the
literature there's not a lot of
information regarding back today the
genomic architecture of breast tumors
not only in the Mexican population but
in the Latino population level we don't
know if there are differences in the
inner mexican population compared with
others but it's important to to address
this for this questions analyzing tumors
from from our own population so we have
been working with different types of a
race from that the metrics in this case
we were using that the affymetrix human
in st 1 array in order to describe
what's the frequency of different breast
cancer subtypes based on the pan 50
algorithm because this was something we
didn't know from our population so the
first thing we did was to run the erase
and classify the tumors they know that
will identify what what's the frequency
of the different chambers subtypes and
based on mrna expression on coding genes
and also we are mainly focusing on the
triple negative tumors using another
type of array front of the neck from a
few metrics that the micro RNA
expression array in order to define a
specific a micronian expression pattern
in triple-negative breast tumors and as
you can see here we are defining a
specific a patterning of micron
expression that can separate the triple
negative from the non triple negative
breast tumors and furthermore we have
analyzed in collaboration with instituto
nacional to morning in Milan in Italy a
good number of triple negative tumors
where we analyze the heterogeneity
within this trip this type of tumors and
we were able to identify a micronian
expression pattern that can identify
those triple negative tumors with a
voice clinical out so this is what we've
been doing regarding the messenger RNA
coding genes and the part of the micro
RNAs which are quite of the update of
the non-coding transcriptome but since
this presentation is mostly a long
non-coding RNAs I will tell you the
results that we've been gathering from
three different projects one is
analyzing the expression patterns of
lincoln relays in different breast
cancer subtypes defined by the pump 50
algorithm and also we are focusing on
the triple negative breast cancer where
we are analyzing the expression partners
of london folding are realizing this
type of chamber and one major difference
between these two types of projects is
that this one the project with it with a
with a different subtypes of breast
cancer we are running fresh frozen
samples with very nice Sam Renee and the
triple negative breast cancer project is
it's from a I can multi shoot
paraffin-embedded tissue and this
represents another layer of complexity
in the analysis and I will show you how
we're dealing with it with a moody
affymetrix arrays so basically what we
are doing is running the expression
analysis using the a matrix human
transcriptome version two where we can
analyze both commenting and non-coding
genes and a single experiment we are
using the current of the metrics tools
report for for expression analysis and
from that information we select set of
lamb non-coding RNAs where we validate
the subtype a specific expression and we
also analyzed the correlation of
expression of the loom non-coding RNAs
with the new by coding Kings in order to
try to find a correlation and try to
define it this if the non-coding RNA is
acting insist a controlling the
expression of the coding I releasing the
new by a low side and of course we are
also trying to validate our findings
using an external in the pen
data set basically we're using the
Chandra database which is the right from
our in a sec experiments at the DC GA
samples and we are also using Chan Rick
in order to find some other interesting
alum non-coding RNAs that we might be
interesting in Eliza ng data biological
world with breast cancer after that ones
that we validated the expression of the
of the London Calling rnase both in our
sample population and in the databases
we use a small hairpin rnas in order to
inhibit the expression of this long
you're calling are releasing different
sets of cell lines and we also analyzed
the effect on transcription of
inhibition of the long term week now
Renee using again they're free matrix
human transcriptome array so now that we
got the information of the
transcriptional consequences of
inhibiting expression of the non-coding
we took that data and analyze what we
wouldn't be the best functional assays
that we want to check in in sell assets
in order to evaluate a phenotypic
consequences of inhibiting the
expression of the London Calling in the
cell lines and the way that we are using
time break in order to identify a
potentially interesting charm mixing
breast cancer is just minding the
database in order to identify
overexpress nominal coding relays which
are related with a clinical outcome and
then but there's nothing in the
literature out there what a potential by
a lot you want so once you identify
those ones we will follow up with that
with a silencing in the cellular models
and also evaluate the potential
biological role of this London Calling
array I realized derive from them
database analysis so and what I can tell
me about the results we will be focusing
first on the on the differential
expression between the different cancer
breast cancer subtypes and we also
included a set of normal adjacent
tissues in this analysis so just to let
you know we identified a good number of
differentially expressed that
transcripts from both coding and
non-coding and this is telling us that
they obviously the expression patterns
of breast cancer
to the normal tissue is highly regulated
both at the coding and non-coding
expression of genes now but furthermore
we also were able to identify a set of
London coding error days which can
separate the normal and then the tumor
tissue this is not new disk as we know
very published by several groups but the
good news is that we applied from
identifying differential expression of
known previously known non-current long
non-coding RNAs really good breast
cancer we are also identifying several
nominal culinary lace who strongly
breast cancer were not previously
described and they obviously represent
interesting potential targets for future
research and the main question of this
protocol was if we were able to define a
specific level culinarian expression
pattern which can separate the different
subtypes of breast cancer and this is
the case we were able to identify
several long non-coding RNAs which can
which are specifically in recent
different subtypes of breast cancer and
again some of them have been already
published but some of them are new
targets that are disappointed validation
in the future the first thing that we do
is to compare their results with that
with tendrich with it with independent
database which of course has a lot of
more samples and it's also derived from
an RNA expression analysis so it will be
an interesting comparison a comparing
data from a limited number of samples in
our cases the right from the erase
against a bigger database with a higher
number of samples land with an
orthogonal a method for detecting the
expression of these London Calling areas
so as you can see here now with samples
we identified several nominal kolega
relay switch which are in wigston de in
the different tumor subtypes and which
are validated in the in the tunnel Rick
database some of them with they are not
not seen as significant as we found in
our data collection but this must be a
number of the it must be a result of the
number of samples that were analyzing in
each case but anyway we selected those
ones where we validated the differential
expression in the specific tumor
subgroup and we carried out the next
experiments and
we decided to select those the
candidates for further research based on
the enriched expression of this molecule
in a single molecular subtype we wanted
to have a holding gene and the new by
region in order to test if this was
there was correlated expression that
might be telling us that there was a
cyst regulation there between the
aluminum coating and the coating and for
that we also analyzed the correlated
expression between the lone encoding and
decoding harmony and if it possible that
the coating i rename must be playing a
rolling and unrolling in some type of
cancer so we selected a set of London
Calling RNA switch to fulfill these
requirements which are involved in
several types of cancer at least at the
RNA level but from which their long
non-coding RNA biological function is
not currently known and we also did the
validation of the correlation between
the homeland coding and decoding RNA
using our samples and the databases in
order to confirm that they were that the
regulation was coordinated and then we
proceeded to the silencing experiments
in the in the particular cell line that
we're expressing the most in London
Calling RNA of our interest using this
short hairpin erase as you can see here
wait wait when we when we shot down an
expression of the aluminum coating I
Renee we also generated the inhibition
of the herbal expression of the coding
nearby gene so this is telling us that
they might be working in correlation and
the long non-coding RNA might be acting
insist controlling the expression of the
coding arenae and when for that in order
to see what would be apart from the new
by dean see how will tag will be the
main effect on a genome-wide expression
changes when you when you shut down that
long non-coding RNA we we set up an
experiment using again a few metrics
already know that to check if there were
all the genes that were overexpressed or
down regulated by the implication of
expression of an unknown
coding RNA and these are the results
when we compared the control cells
against the assignment selves we
identified at least 208 transcripts that
were differentially expressed between
the expression by the expression of the
of the Loom non-coding RNA once we got
this information from the array we run
the analysis that pathway analysis
enrichment and we identified several a
cellular pathways which are rather
relevant for breast cancer and then I
modified by the inhibition of the
expression of Islam non-coding RNA so
now I'm going to change to the second
project which is the triple negative
breast cancer which as I told you this
is the right mainly from samples to
entire paraffin-embedded at tribal
tissue it's always great to if you're
able to work with archival tissue
because you can do you can do
retrospective analysis and it's always a
good way to increase your number of
samples but of course working with
paraffin is some time it's on how
difficult because the degradation of the
nucleic acid that is difficult to work
with but in order to test it we can if
the array was able to work with
paraffin-embedded samples and with hair
is strongly the grated DNA listen up the
final experiment we had the same samples
fresh frozen and paraffin-embedded so we
we carried out there an extraction and
run the same array using the fresh
frozen tissue on the paraffin-embedded
and as you can see through the
correlation between the two is it's good
but what we learn from this experiment
is that most of the samples when did we
are not correlated that the sample some
work-related when you analyze
paraffin-embedded tissue and also that
you have a high correlation when you
when you are lies fresh tissue only when
you compare the fresh-baked correlation
between the threat the first person and
the paraffin-embedded tissue the
correlation goes no way but it is still
usable for the discovery of differential
gene expression patterns so this this is
more clear in here when you compare two
different samples which are both fresh
you had a very good correlation on the
data when you compare two different
samples
which are both paraffin-embedded the
correlation was a little bit down
because of this degradation of RNA and
when you when you compare the fresh
tissue against the parameter in the
tissue the correlation goes even down
but it's still usable the data is still
usable and well there is you should
always work with if you are going to
study different sets of cures you should
all do too much mostly paraffin-embedded
or your August issues must be fresh then
you shouldn't mix them in a single
experiment but anyway the information
that you can gather from from
paraffin-embedded tissue is useful for
the analysis and discovery of non-coding
RNAs which are differentially expressed
in your introduction so the main
questions that we had is if we were able
to identify specific patterns of lamb
non-coding RNA expression which can
separate the triple negative breast
tumors on the different subtypes defined
by messenger RNA expression and this is
the case you can see here in the heat
map you can find a specific groups of
London color harmonies which are
enriched in a particular a bright red
triple negative breast cancer subtypes
we also evaluated this our findings in
an independent data set this was a very
nice opportunity because this paper by
ely 2016 they also analyzed up large 4.2
triple negative tumors using the exact
same array the human transcriptome
version 2 array so it was a very nice
opportunity to compare the
reproducibility of their of the array in
a specific biology biological setting in
two different settings and in two
different independent groups and
fortunately we were able to validate the
expression data that we got in our
samples from paired with a with
independent data set and from that from
this data we selected one of the links
are one of the Lincoln relays which was
enriching name of them in nunavut
electronic triple negative subtype can
we carried out that the inhibition of
this long non-coding RNA and also using
arrays and we needed to fight genoqs
alone including any expression pattern
which is
which is generated by the inclusion of
this long non-coding RNA in the triple
negative seven that we used for this
experiment again we're under the pathway
analysis enrichment and we also find
that this long non-coding RNA infusion
is affecting cellular pathways that are
very relevant to breast cancer
development and this will lead the next
experiments in order to see what would
will be the best experiments to do in
the cell lines in order to to to define
their biological world in breast cancer
so in conclusion and Lincoln relays are
a major source of useful information to
correct as breast cancer heterogeneity
result of thing with one technological
platform are comparable to others they
erase and they're realistic data are at
least in the tendency of the elder
expression of time regulation are
comparable you can identify targets in a
limited number of sample but you can
identify mean a new qaballah date with
independent sample student through the
use of public databases and also a link
RNA expression stem can can be analyzed
from fresh frozen and paraffin-embedded
tissue using the race and finally we
have identified a set of London Calling
I realize whose expression is not
written several breast cancer subtypes
and are involved in the regulation of
the expression of important cellular
pathways related to cancer so the next
steps are defining what would be the
best way signal to identify the
biological role of this long non-coding
RNAs if they're involved in acting like
sponges for my coronation for example
and for that we are trying to set up
several protocols in order to question
to address this question you know in
that so with that I would like to finish
just like thanking all the patients that
participated and I will study our
collaborators in their instituto
nacional good morning Talia definition
consegui mama here in Mexico City
affymetrix for providing most of the
race that we used in this experiment the
National Council of science and
technology which is our funding source
and
microwave eunuch here at the national
institute of genomic medicine for
running a race that we use for this
project thank you very much doctor thank
you very much for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we're going to
try to answer as many questions as we
can and remember all questions that are
not answered will be answered offline
via email our first question goes to dr.
DeVoe how did you initially do that I L
and C RNA using an tray or by some qpcr
or some other technique thank you um so
the linkery was initially identified so
that Barney was extracted from the
biopsies and RNA seek and sorry
sequencing libraries were constructed
followed by RNA sequencing on the
alumina hi seek 2000 analyzer now the
library were aligned to an extensive
catalog of published link on a data sets
sorry including combined predictions
from the gene cohen project project
linked rnase discovered and annotated by
the ring lab as well as link RNA is
predicted by the bartell lab in addition
to UCSC reference sequence genes and
rolling out link RNA is that had coding
potential so we initially discovered our
link are in a cohort just through RNA
sequencing and then we've moved into
qpcr for validation of expression in our
multiple centaline systems that answers
right on our next question is for dr.
Miranda what percentage of known lncrnas
is covered by HT a 2 point 0 arrays how
actual is there annotations there are
different databases for lncrnas is HT a
2 point 0 annotation related to a
specific one of them well yes at least
if if you go to the affymetrix webpage
they can tell you where where they got
the information in order to print it the
probes that they are analyzing with this
type of array it's a we had some
problems with the annotation and but
basically what we are finding is that
it's a very well very good coverage at
least from the one of the best versions
of know of non-coloured or rain colony
and it's a nice tool in order to
identify differentially expressed
micrornas non-coding RNAs and it's also
very important I stool if you want to
compare in the same experiment both
aluminum coating expression and the
coding expression in that way you can
correlate the expression of both and you
might be able to answer some other
biological question with the same
platform and obviously since you are
using an array a there will be always
newer versions and actually right now I
think the new equation of the erase that
there are new merchant of these arrays
that can have a more comprehensive
coverage of London coding RNA at this
time
and thank you a doctor fellow what
experiments are planned to specifically
tackle the genomic locus of ln c 7 and
its potential effect on nearby p c geez
great thanks for the question that is
the driving force of what we are
continuing to do so for the directly
associated protein coding gene giving
our initial findings we are getting
ready to perform a nuclear run-on assay
following depletion of our link ironing
to directly determine if the link RNA is
playing a role with transcription
initiation now concerning further
protein coding genes not that one that's
only directly overlapped will be using
qpcr analysis to see if knockdown will
also impact additional genes now
considering the enhancer question which
I find very very exciting most enhancer
interactions are will occur within 50
kilobases of that enhancer and so we
will initially focus our studies there
for the potentially distal interactions
that could be taking place we are hoping
to do chirp seek whereby we can
determine where the link RNA is actually
touching in the genome though we have
not gotten there yet and we would like
to overlap that with with some chromatin
some capture see studies in order to
look at chromatin structure in which
chromosomes are actually having
connections following the link RNA
depletion now the one caveat to this is
all of those studies so far our
depletion studies we are actively
pursuing trying to do an overexpression
study however we're challenged by the
fact that we believe this link are any
functions insists an expression off of a
plasmid might not be sufficient for
phenotypic analysis and so we are
currently working on using crisper to
activate endogenous transcription from
this locus and then study the impacts of
the
on both protein-coding genes nearby as
well as potential impact on enhancer
chromatin looping thank you in several
of our attendees have asked for contact
information we've just been informed
here that the collaboration will be via
email offline so there will be a notice
that is sent out in regards to contact
for that i'm dr. Hidalgo Miranda I do
have a question for you what is the
advantage of using SH RNA or si RNA vs
chris burke asinine for silencing
editing the ln c RNA of interest well
that's a very good question and I think
we've also tried to we're setting up the
crisp methodology in order to fully
inhibit expression of the of the link i
relay you might you might have a less of
target whistles when you use crisper but
the shrna is a easy method is a decent
way to do it and we wanted to explore
what we found first in order to to just
do the inhibition using the short
hairpin know it is RNA but of course
Chris Berg is more it might be more
efficient both in the indentation and
you might get less of target events that
might be in that Libya even useful in
order to check this kind of experiments
but I mean it's you can get information
from outside of remote from both methods
but Christopher might give you a cleaner
answer for that particular experiment
would like to thank the audience for the
outstanding questions and participation
and I also like to thank our doctors for
their informative presentations dr.
devote any final comments before we let
you go today I just want to again say
thank you for the opportunity to speak
with all of you today and I think this
is great and I have seen a few comments
or potentially in future collaborations
on both scientifically and potentially
with samples I think that's absolutely
wonderful thank you very much for for
your time thank you dr. develop and dr.
to hidalgo Miranda I do you have any
final comments before we let you go well
against and I would like to join Rebecca
for thanking you for your attention this
has been a great experience and of
course we are also very interested in
following up with that with a attendance
in order to find some potential
collaboration in the future I will just
like to thank both affymetrix and
lapid's for the opportunity and Rebecca
for your presentation and hopefully we
can work together with some of you in
the future Peggy doctors it's been my
pleasure being your moderator for today
I also like to thank our sponsor
affymetrix for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing during wolf 2017 and will
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to for that
announcements your colleagues who have
may have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye